[Music]
go Luke yeah we messed whooped your ass
again didn't he
it was the other way around man oh no
where's the video of that [ __ ] you still
to hero our Harlem right my cousin's
getting smacked around by the cops cuz
he has dreads every Jamaican ain't down
with Bushmaster hey you need to handle
this loop my little sister can't even
sleep at night what are you good at you
know I'm doing the best I can okay look
I'm sorry about your bredrin
and I'm a handle Bushmaster and young
lady I promise I'm gonna put a stop to
all of this damn she got you that's some
cold [ __ ] let's go see you use your
powers right excuse me you see if I was
bulletproof and strong I'd be running
[ __ ] I'd be like either you bend a knee
while you lay down [ __ ] and if they
didn't two cameras like straight planes
for the [ __ ] estate property and Game
of Thrones do not mix now when you hacks
that she sounds right
are you coming in as you never asked
[Music]
[Applause]
drue chorus everyone I love the fact
that they dropped Game of Thrones in
firebombing and then that Punisher clip
is literally of jigsaw and Punisher
lighting each other up with machine guns
so there's obviously two different
things going on here one is a clip from
Punisher season 2 the other being Luke
Cage which is dropping at the end of
June so if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
all the Marvel videos this is just the
beginning there's gonna be a whole bunch
of more stuff dropping but how funny is
it that like right after I do a
daredevil video all this Luke Cage and
punisher stuff starts dropping is like
today's suddenly turned into Netflix day
and I even actually had some new
immortal weapons iron fist season 2
stuff that I had to cut out of this
video because it was just too much going
on but I'll start with the Luke Cage
footage then I'll do the Punisher
footage so the whole deal with the Luke
Cage stuff is it looks like it happens
right after he gets his ass handed to
him by Bushmaster it gets uploaded to
YouTube so everybody here just making
fun of him like dude when he gonna start
fixing things and they all turn into
critics like they think that they could
do a better job with his powers than he
could
the real comedy of this moment being the
kid not realizing that what he's
describing basically turns him into a
villain like Luke Cage is trying to be a
hero so it's not like he wants to set
everything on fire even though there are
portions of the trailer where he
literally sets himself on fire yo I'm
Luke Cage don't test me you know where
to find me Shekhar's
like he blows himself up here in this
truck while he's filming the Heroes for
Hire commercial so he can show everyone
what a badass he is the thing about his
powers you have to remember that his
skin is invulnerable but his incise his
internal organs are not that was the big
thing during Jessica Jones season one
letting you know that like a shotgun to
the head can really rattle him now he
wouldn't have died from that but he
probably would have been in a coma for a
long time
[Music]
but I've already done a video about
bushmaster and how in the comics he's
basically almost the exact same thing as
Luke Cage but the TV show looks like
it's put a slightly different spin on
that but given him the same power level
the big difference being that he's
really badass with martial arts Luke
Cage is not like he's really strong but
I used the Man of Steel analogy like
during that movie the Kryptonians come
to earth Superman can barely fight them
because he hasn't trained to fight and
they've been training their entire lives
because they're military
the big joke being that iron fist is
around it looks like he's gonna be
helping him with that problem at least
briefly right now I believe they're
actually still filming iron fist season
two and they're still wrapping up
daredevil season 3 kingpin has finished
on daredevil season 3 but I think they
still have a little bit more stuff to do
the deal with Punisher is that they just
started filming a little while ago and
obviously jigsaw is back you can't tell
from this video but obviously his face
is gonna be crazy scarred up not as bad
as it is in the comics but I'm guessing
that there's gonna be heavy prosthetics
in a mixture of a little bit of CG to
tune it up but like we had the joke
about Game of Thrones in the Luke Cage
clip Tyrion is a good example if you're
not a big Game of Thrones fan in the
books he gets his face scarred his nose
is chopped off but on the TV show they
just gave him like a scar across his
nose instead of making him look really
hideous so I'm just guessing same type
of treatment for Billy Russo Jake saw in
season 2 they haven't said much about
what the plot is actually going to be
there's no synopsis for it yet they've
just been filming outside that's how we
have this footage but I'm guessing
because they tore down Billy Russo's
organization like it was all about
dismantling all the legal stuff that was
going on I'm guessing that he's either
just coming up to the Punisher rogue by
himself or they're doing the comic book
thing where he starts working for the
mob speaking of Punisher daredevil
crossover like I just did that bullseye
video so in Punisher max bullseye was a
character it seems like that version of
bullseye is gonna be the basis for the
daredevil season 3 version of bullseye
so it's getting really meta here but the
cool thing about that Punisher max
storyline is that Wilson Fisk starts out
as an enforcer for the mob eventually
his boss ends up
dying so kingpin seizes power and uses
bullseye to go after the Punisher so
like you already have bits of these
stories that they've borrowed and put
other places they did a little bit of
Punisher max during Punisher season one
but they really didn't have him going
after the mob as much as they did during
daredevil season two so I'm hoping that
they jump back on that line because
there's a lot of organized crime in the
city Punisher versus the mob has been a
big thing in the comics for a long time
so there's just a lot for them to mine
there especially with the kingpin slowly
ceasing all the mob bosses territories
so do not forget that the Punisher and
kingpin have unfinished business the
last time they saw each other in the
prison they said next time we meet one
of us isn't walking away so it's like he
has a vendetta against Punisher just
like he has a vendetta against Matt
Murdock and against the daredevil you
see when I finally let out of this cage
it won't be to wage war it will be twin
one I'm really hoping to did they work
up to another defenders crossover with
the kingpin being the main villain and
you have jigsaw over from The Punisher
series working for him eventually like
we have bullseye coming to daredevil
season 3 I'm hoping what they do is
another year or two they work up to
another defender's team up and you have
some of these smaller villains like
jigsaw bullseye working for the kingpin
I know I've got a lot of electric
questions too I don't know if she's
coming back I haven't heard anything but
it's always possible so let me know in
the comments what do you think about all
the footage and what do you want them to
do for the next defenders team up like
kingpin becomes the big bad do you want
to see all these smaller villains
working for him like the defenders
versus the dark defenders if anybody
remembers Dark Reign Norman Osborn's
Dark Avengers that would actually be a
pretty fun thing to do in the TV
universe but if you haven't seen it I
just posted a daredevil season 3
bullseye video click here to watch that
and click here for brand new ant-man
footage thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight